hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished to him a banana show
and who may give us a really modern
collection that was a complete
juxtaposition of formal wear and regular
tailoring meeting street where I think
he really hit it dead on the money with
this collection this is how guys really
dressed you know by combining tailored
pieces with more Street where items he
really has a grasp on what men are
wearing these days you know I love how
he had the tailored jackets mixed with
the more elasticized wasted sweatpant
rousers some of the tops were a little
bit more voluminous and then there are
also these great tapered pants it's like
when you get out of it you see these
really cool guys and they have on like
suit jackets with sweat pants and
sneakers you know I love that they're
all these great high top throughout your
show the color palette was dark these
were aggressive clothes but also really
beautiful this set was filled with
dedenne viens of the night we had
[ __ ] we had hot dog vendors we had
garbage we had four PT artists and I
just love that that really made sense
with the clothing and it really made
sense from his point of view this is
where he's coming from and this is what
he thinks is really new and fresh and
I'm totally agree for more videos from
Milan please check out details calm and
you can always follow me on instagram
and twitter at details matter